foreign
my guest this week is Professor Brian
Keating and he almost won the Nobel
Prize and today we're going to find out
just what it feels like to lose it uh
it's a really cool story he set up the
bicep 2 telescope in Antarctica and it
looked like him and his colleagues had
made a unique Discovery and there was a
roller coaster of what actually happened
and some disputes about the data and
what it showed there's politics from the
Nobel Prize Association and I didn't
understand what it was or how it works
how it's Chosen and what the processes
and the heritage of this particular
organization are but we're going to find
all of that out today it's very
interesting story albeit
at the expense of Professor Keating but
if you enjoyed this episode go back and
check out the ones with Sabina
hosenfelder and Professor Adam Frank
they're both fantastic physicists and
they have a lot to add to this
discussion about the politics of science
obviously if you love the episode please
share it it makes me very happy but for
now let's welcome Professor Keating oh
yeah PS I've started to shorten down the
intros to these podcasts because I
respect your time and I found myself
skipping through a lot of the
introductions to podcasts that I listen
to as well in future I'm going to
Endeavor to keep them around about one
minute I think this should be enough
time to tell you about the guest and
inform you of any upcoming announcements
which are important but if you feel like
you need to know more or less if you
want me to chop it down even further and
just say hi friends then let me know at
Chris willex on all social media
[Music]
thank you
Professor Brian Keating how are you
today
I'm fantastic Chris thanks for having me
on it's an absolute pleasure so what are
we going to learn about today
well you know I kind of sought out your
podcast so I don't know how usual that
is but I heard my friend uh Mario Olivio
on your show about two months ago a
month and a half ago
and the interview that you did was uh
was phenomenal and of course he's such
an engaging and erudite fellow that I
felt like it would be a good opportunity
for me to share some of the ideas that
I've been thinking about in my work as a
cosmologist as I point out I don't do
hair and nails but I am a cosmetologist
although a lot of people think I I do
until they meet me
nor do I tell horoscopes but uh but
instead what I look for is really the
earliest evidence for the beginning of
the universe and what I thought is so
interesting about the perspective that
colleagues such as myself can provide in
contradistinction to those of you know
these erudite brilliant folks you've had
on like Mario
um is that I'm an experimentalist so an
experimentalist as a as a cosmologist it
doesn't mean that we build universes I
I've got a healthy ego but not quite
that healthy
um but to think that I could actually
build the universe but instead we build
telescopes that will allow us hopefully
to reveal the earliest evidence for
what's known as The Big Bang and how we
came to know what the universe is
comprised of
along the way May hopefully be revealed
through the types of telescopes that
myself and my colleagues built and this
is very different from those of the
professions you know as practiced by uh
your your you know late countrymen and
my distant late colleague Stephen
Hawking or or uh sir Roger Penrose who
recently visited me in San Diego and was
part of our podcast that we run for the
Arthur C Clarke Center here in San Diego
and that was uh that is you know to
study the universe from a purely
theoretical point of view is absolutely
necessary and I always say you know some
of my best friends are theoretical
physicists but but in reality we we have
uh learned much more about the universe
uh from people that build instruments
whether it be Galileo or Newton
or you know people that that uh are
connected deeply to instrumentation
because there are very few theories in
the world if you think about it there
philosophically there can only be so
many different descriptions of how the
the actual World Works many fewer than
how possible worlds could work and I'll
give you one example and maybe we'll
talk about that at greater length today
uh for uh for those in the audience who
may have heard of something called the
Multiverse uh this is a very
controversial subject within physics and
even philosophy and it really revolves
around the notion of whether our
universe is alone whether ours is the
only Universe both that exists now or
may have ever existed or may will ever
exist in a distant future
and that's quite an astounding thing to
think about uh it's motivated in some
sense from the thought of people like
Copernicus and Galileo who showed the
Earth is just but one of many planets in
the solar system uh now we know there's
but one of the Milky Ways but one of
many galaxies in the universe so perhaps
it's it's natural to think maybe we're
just the not just the only Universe in
What's called the Multiverse so these
are the kind of things we study but uh
but in in contrast to many other you
know kind of more popular maybe much
smarter uh they're better speakers than
my than I am but uh these these folks
that study things from a purely
theoretical perspective it's just a
different perspective I thought it would
be great for your audience to get a
taste them I I couldn't agree more
how different is the or how bipartisan
is the world of physics when it comes to
the experimentalists versus the
theoretical lists yeah the theory
yeah it's kind of like you know
Republicans and Democrats that's really
what it's like Corey's and Leia no it's
it's much healthier than that uh I would
say it's it's like uh it's it's much
less of a rivalry than any you know
sports team is it like the offensive
team in the defensive team of American
football yeah except you know I wouldn't
want to wager on you know the
theoreticians I know to to be very good
footballers
you'll edit that out I think that no I
think I think Mario I wouldn't back
going up against Mario Olivio he seems
like he's probably got a bit of a bit of
a vicious streak to him when he needs to
get going he's got a massive side that's
right
indeed yeah they're they're uh there
there is a I'd say a healthy rivalry as
there should be so it used to be I don't
know how it is in the UK whether you're
football teams there uh but in America
there used to be laws uh in unofficial
laws Within sports teams for our version
of football that if you're playing
against you know an opposing team in
American football you weren't allowed to
socialize with them the night before the
game like they're called
anti-fraternization laws like well
that's not really very friendly you know
that's not very gentlemanly but of
course you know if our version of
football yeah we wear helmets and you
guys in rugby and football are kind of
uh you know different that way but um
but there was a rivalry and you want to
stoke that competition and that those
juices because it was thought that
competition would be compromised if they
were too friendly
and you know I just you know contrast
that to the word fraternization means
fraternal I have three brothers of my
own and I don't think we'd ever
characterize our relationship you know
as very you know friendly and in a
competition even even a physical one so
um so perhaps that's Miss name but I
think there should be a skepticism you
know it's very easy to write uh papers
and and conjecture marvelous things like
wormholes and extra dimensions and the
Multiverse and things like that it's
it's it's easy in some sense of course
intellectually it's very challenging to
actually be able to back that up but
it's it's sort of you when there's no
um when there's nothing no skin in the
game as Nicholas taleb says you know
there's nothing really that they're not
gonna go out there and build the
experiment to detect it and that's very
different than the way things used to be
right Galileo would have an idea that
falling masses you know uh decelerate or
accelerate towards the Earth at the same
rate regardless of their mass or
composition
and uh and he showed that and he built
an apparatus allegedly the Leaning Tower
of Pisa Etc but he did other things that
we know are not apocryphal a
newton-built telescopes and he built uh
he built other apparatus he was of
course an alchemist and
um you know he was actually involved in
the day-to-day events of the world but
um and even Einstein had patents which
is quite amazing to think about and um
and of course you know the great
physicist of the 20th and 21st century
many of them you know had equal facility
with experiment in theory and I think
that's the nature of a well-rounded
renaissance man or woman physicist that
we should aspire to be uh capable of of
forays into both the purely abstruse
theoretical domain and what it actually
takes to have skin in the game to go out
and measure it and so I get that
completely is it um it seems like the
sky's the limit really oh actually no
because that's probably a poor term to
use in your field of work right but um
the something is the limit uh for
theoretical physicists as you've said
they can if they can postulate it and
back it up with an existing Theory which
again can also be based on something
which hasn't been shown to be true in
experiment but perhaps make sense
mathematically given the constants that
we know about the universe etc etc that
they can say it and put it forward and
downstream from that there's actually no
real implications other than oh wow you
wrote a really cool theory about this
particular thing let's run with it and
see if anyone else fancies backing it up
that's right yeah exactly so it's a I
kind of view in this maybe your your
listeners and maybe you'll appreciate
the analogy it's kind of like I feel we
as experimentalists are the bouncers in
the nightclub of the universe and that
we actually are the ones that that
squash and keep things out and keep the
field honest in a sense and and it can
also happen to us as I describe in my
book so my book is called losing the
Nobel Prize and it's a story it's really
kind of like
um the dirty laundry or or confidential
you know kind of uh tell-all about what
it's like to be a professional scientist
in this current ERA and that also means
that sometimes you get swept up in sort
of the pursuit of things that are
non-scientific in nature and that they
may be related to benefiting your career
or your pocketbook or what have you
um and this is a relatively new
Affliction you know I don't think uh
very many people in the olden days were
concerned as much about Fame and and
fortune in science and it's certainly
true that you know Einstein didn't die a
billionaire right I mean he his his
ideas in some sense were responsible for
a lot of the technology from GPS to the
laser you know he made some money but he
wasn't born but if you look at how much
he could have contributed intellectually
versus monetarily it's vastly outweighed
so I think that it's important as I say
in my book you know we can write a book
about the Multiverse or the Wormhole or
the black hole or but you can't really
put it on the cover of the book whereas
the every single book comes with a dust
jacket right and and what does it do
it's what keep dust out I mean I always
hated dust jackets and I always thought
they were useless and they'd get in the
way of the book
um but now I realize that they serve
this vital purpose which is to keep the
dust out of the story and the story in
my case is intricately uh dependent on
the role that dust in the cosmos this in
this case plays and so I say to my
friend you know try getting a wormhole
jacket on the cover and I'll be very
impressed I get that so losing the Nobel
Prize tell us where does the book begin
what's the story
so it's really a three-part Story one
part is a memoir of what it's like to be
a cosmologist to work with some of the
biggest minds intellects and egos in the
world at The Cutting Edge of
astronomical Discovery in this case we
built the telescope that we put at the
very bottom of the world at a location
called the South Pole which is the sort
of central uh part of the Antarctic
continent reached for the second time in
1912 by one of your countrymen Robert
Falcon Scott He famously arrived there
just three weeks later than his
Norwegian counterpart Ronald amundsen
and that three-week delay ended up
costing him and five of his um of his
employees if you will their lives and I
draw some parallels between the quest to
conquer Antarctica and the South Pole in
particular and the quest to be the first
in science to make a discovery to make a
discovery that is as as important as is
foundational and as is important career
rise to its discoverers as the finding
of the South Pole was or the landing on
the moon in the 1960s was for America
so that's part one what's it like to be
a scientist at the bleeding edge of
competition uh collaboration and and in
some cases controversy
is there not very many uh bits of
low-hanging fruit you've said it's kind
of like a winner take all competition
here and you know if you want to be the
first person to reach a pole in the
world you've only got two choices right
like you're gonna that's it once one's
gone there's only one left and once that
one's gotten you first so is it
similarly uh is it is it kind of um
needles in a haystack so to speak in
terms of finding like the big winners
well you know there's a famous quote by
uh John Archibald wheeler who was you
know Feynman one of feynman's advisors
and and so forth
um but uh that was you know our job is
to expand the island of knowledge into
the sea of ignorance something to that
effect but when you make an island
bigger you're also making the coastline
between the border between ignorance and
knowledge bigger and elongated as well
so I think that's sort of the job there
it's harder and harder to find New
Frontiers that's certainly true but
there's so many Mysteries there's so
many things that are just staring us
right in the face that we know nothing
about that some have decried the
stagnation in cosmology and physics in
particular and really this glorification
of the past is a symptom of the of the
relative Backwater stagnation that's
occurring within physics today namely
that there haven't been according to a
German physicist Sabine hasenfelder make
a good guess someday for you as well
we had a discussion I was going to bring
up I was going to mention some of that
with you as well so we'll get into that
in a second what was that what was the
quote that you had from her well it's
really just the claim from her that
there there haven't been any
developments in nearly 50 years that
rival the developments of say the
preceding 50 years in physics and that
is you know and that is kind of
depressing on one hand but I note that
she's a theoretician she's not an
experimentalist and that's why I think
it's it's so exciting to be someone who
can build interact and acquire data from
these Sentinels whether they be located
underground in space at the South Pole
in the Atacama Desert in Chile and I
think it's the most exciting time in
history from that perspective so I don't
disagree with her that you know she may
have chosen poorly in her field Choice
uh we have a friendly kind of uh rivalry
she's awesome yeah she's she's uh she's
a certain contrarian
um and so what uh what I really feel is
that the it couldn't be more Stark the
contrast and the kind of ebullience and
excitement that I feel every day getting
to do what I do versus kind of the
depression and sullenness and I see from
my theory theoretical colleague so I'm
always trying to convert them you know
and get them out of there
yeah exactly get them on the other side
of the team I love it so what's what's
part two
part two is really a story of how we
came to know what we know about
cosmology so a history of the Universe
from the first telescope ever used in
astronomy by Galileo up through the
bicep 2 telescope which is a telescope
that I conceived of and helped to build
at the South Pole Antarctica that seemed
to provide evidence for what was claimed
to be the biggest discovery of all time
the day we made the announcement and
certain to rack up numerous Nobel prizes
for those of us potentially who built
the instrument and certainly for the
theoreticians who made the predictions
uh and how do they you know the
inflationary universe that I describe
how did that come to be and whatever its
implications as I said the Multiverse is
a natural extension it's a consequence
according to the founders of inflation
without uh without the inflationary
Universe you know being true there would
be no Multiverse and and only if there
is inflation can there be a Multiverse
in many of these theories so it's
incredibly uh high stakes for cosmology
and for philosophy and all of physics
that we get this right and our
experiment claimed evidence for this
back in 2014 uh to Global headlines and
Fanfare Nobel Prize Whispers uh we later
had to retract that statement in that
claim and what that experience was like
as a physicist and as a human being I
think you know when you interview these
brilliant people
um I think the lay person is most
interested in what are they like as as a
person like you know uh what was
Einstein like as a father that's
something that's always interested me
like what was uh you know Feynman like
as as a friend those are more
interesting like I can learn the physics
the physics is sort of immutable it's
it's like you know it's it's it's it's
it's it's possible to learn the physics
about knowing the the personality behind
it but that's why these biographies of
Einstein and and Feynman that keep
coming out it's like how many
biographies can you have you know it's
like did he have a secret double yeah
clone somewhere I think if if anyone was
gonna have a double or triple a
quadruple life it would be Richard
Feynman that's the discussion I had with
Mario Olivio I think as close as Mario
Olivio can have a man crush on someone I
think Richard Feynman just about might
be it what what's super interesting you
said that talking as a perfect
representative of the layperson when it
comes to physics
um I hadn't taken a massive interest in
Isaac Newton until I found out about all
of his very strange quirks and beliefs
and how he used to love to go to
hangings and he kind of had a little bit
of a sadistic side to him and he spent
more than half his career trying to
um prove a bunch of theological uh stuff
to be true and you know and I'm like oh
like gravity like I want to know
about what I want to know about like his
weird quirks and all right do you know
like that it humanizes yeah you're
totally right did you did you never hear
what he claimed as his greatest
accomplishment for the man who came up
with Calculus the law of universal
gravity lay it on us he that he died a
virgin
that I remember hearing that he claimed
with his grace because it was as close
as he could get to emulating Jesus
Christ and it shows you the esteem with
which he held uh now I'm not for you
know deconstructing just to tear
somebody down you know like oh George
Washington wasn't great because he had
slaves no um that's although I do kind
of deconstruct the Nobel institution in
the book and that's the third part of
the book yeah because what does it mean
because what what ended up happening was
uh I I was you know we made this
announcement I had kind of been edged
out in a dramatic series of events from
the you know basically denied the
paternity of the experiment that I
helped desire so let's just let's just
roll roll back a tiny little bit so
we've got the bicep two telescope
um first off why is it called the bicep
telescope why is it bicep at all so the
the inflationary Universe predicts that
if inflation took place the universe
would be suffused with what's known as
gravitational waves these are waves of
the gravitational force field so as they
pass by a person say if that was uh
possible to imagine the person would
gain and lose weight alternatively as
the wave propagates by so it changed the
force in which gravity is pulling on you
obviously on Earth it wouldn't make any
big difference but but say foreign
Interstellar space you know potentially
this thought experiment you could do now
you know that these gravitational waves
were first detected directly uh in 2015
resulting in the ligo that experiment
leadership or at least three of the four
people that that did it and winning the
Nobel Prize it's a problem that we can
talk about and then uh that was for the
coalescence of two black holes of the
mass each one about 30 tons the mass of
the Sun they came together and made a
black hole that was slightly less
massive than a black hole with the mass
of 59 solar masses say so one entire
Mass was converted to gravitational
energy it couldn't be converted to light
these black holes by by virtue of their
intense gravity are black and so they
coalesce they give off by Einstein's
equation equals m c squared they
converted one solar mass worth of mass
not you know their their gravitational
binding energy into pure gravitational
wave energy that if you can imagine all
the mass in the universe not just 30
Mass black hole 30 solar as black holes
every black hole every Galaxy every
person every single pla everything in
the universe exploding forth not just
over the course of a second as these
black holes call us but over the course
of a trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second how violent that
process would be that would create waves
of gravitational energy
those waves uh would travel at the speed
of light and they would influence the
oldest light that we know to exist in
the universe and that's called The
Cosmic microwave background radiation
it's a type of microwave energy radio
energy that comes to us in all
directions that energy would be twisted
and and curled in a certain way that I
described in the book with about 60
illustrations Uh custom made for the
book and that twisting curling pattern
was known as B mode polarization or curl
pattern polarization and so when I made
up the acronym bicep I wanted to reflect
that we're trying to muscle our way back
to the beginning of time and get the the
the the jump on these curls so the bicep
does the curling on your body so that's
the origin of the name it's such a good
name yeah that's a very clever way to do
it and this gym Bros up and down the
country that are uploading you for
coming up with it as well so we've got
the telescope I'm going to imagine it
must have been an absolutely massive
undertaking to be able to to come up
with something like that and it's in the
most inhospitable climate on the planet
that is the most remote with the least
supplies and all the rest of it so what
was the process like of actually
creating it so creating it you know I
always say was less difficult than
actually you know like coming up with
the idea was harder than actually
building the thing because I'm sorry
sorry for interrupting is that a um is
that a reflection of the theoretical
versus experimental debate again yeah
exactly so very figuratively yeah it's
very hard to convince other people what
a great genius you are you know so but
it turns out you need to in order to
have the wherewithal financial and the
most valuable Capital human capital and
getting young people to believe in your
ideas and to follow you literally to the
ends of the Earth as they did
um and then to actually build the
instrument you know is an engineering
challenge but it's not an insurmountable
one now I I say so with a little bit of
glibness but in truth I have to give
credit to these hard extremely hard
working people in the field like my
students and my collaborators all around
the world because this telescope was
actually able to be cooled down to a
temperature that's 10 times lower than
the temperature of interstellar space
which is it's just unfathomable so a
quarter of a degree above absolute zero
so if you could cool something down to
absolute zero all of its motion all the
chemicals all the molecules would stop
completely stop dead and perhaps if
there's no motion there's no time right
so time is really measured by the
Reckoning between successive events well
if nothing's moving no time could elops
and that's deeply connected with this
theory of inflation
so how do you go from non-universe to
Universe you know it's kind of a big
mystery right it's it's like going from
non-life like just chemicals pouring
chemicals together and getting something
living and so for me to go from
non-experiment to experiment although
that's the zero to one moment in Peter
thiel's language I know you like him uh
you know going to that to that extreme
is uh is is very difficult but it's not
as hard as getting all the assets
together like a military campaign to the
bottom of the world so that took four or
five years to do then by nature of the
faintness of the signal we had to
observe for for a total of between the
two experiments that I was a part of
that made this announcement possible six
years of observation and then another
four years of data analysis on super
computers uh you know just running
non-stop the biggest most massive
computers on Earth and that uh and then
50 people working you know at some times
day and night around the clock to make
this announcement that we had seen the
spark that ignited the very big bang
that we believe exists today so you saw
or the six years of uh capture were done
then further four years of processing
and at the end of that what what
happened because someone someone at some
point has come into the room and said
something like Professor Kate in I think
we found it like that point must have
occurred can you can you talk us through
that
yeah so that's the that's one of the
ironies of the book and one of the
things I think the book does a job a
good job at attempting to describe is
how human scientists are so what you
just described is is the confirmation of
a theory right you said someone can't I
think we found it so that's like Eureka
what does eureka mean when Archimedes
would say I mean I found it so to find
something means you were looking for
something right unless you're just like
ah I saw like that's weird uh and that
happens a lot in science too and I argue
in the book that's the purest form of
scientific discovery when it's
serendipitous
like the deep deep Fields image right
like there's this big blank space we're
just gonna point the thing happens yeah
or closer to where you are now Jocelyn
Bell discovering pulsars for the first
time completely accidentally she wasn't
looking for pulsars it just showed up in
her data and she did the hard work to
unravel it and eventually a Nobel Prize
was awarded uh for her work but not to
her to her male advisors as I point out
on the book but uh exactly so there's
serendipitous discoveries those are pure
those cannot be found and they're also
not susceptible to what's known as
confirmation bias if you have some idea
about me or you know you're you're
bouncing at a club or something you have
to have some notion about you know
what's desirable or what you're what
you're looking for but in science we
like to think that scientists are
completely dispassionate but what if
there are non-scientific forces at work
um such as you know people like me who
at the time was really obsessed with the
Nobel Prize and winning it and and and
being elevated to this very very tiny
Pantheon of scientists who are household
names that that was so enticing it
really dominated a lot of my early
career
um mental energy and so when we yes when
we did discover the signal that I knew
if correct even when I came up with the
idea for the experiment would be the
biggest you know home run or uh what do
you call it Century hitting a century I
don't know
um and Cricket the the idea of doing
that was so intoxicating to both
discover the purity of the scientific
Quest but also being honest to win a
Nobel Prize when we did that one of
course then we just basically you know
looked in as many places as we could to
see if we were right or not and I kept
coming up that we were and uh and but
but the farther we went down the more
committed to the hypothesis confirmation
we were as well and then the ultimate
Revelation was done
not in a peer-reviewed journal article
as typically required as the gold
standard of scientific discovery but
only since the late 1800s by the way but
nevertheless that that Discovery was
announced you know at a press conference
held at Harvard University on March 17
2014 to as I said worldwide Fanfare with
Nobel laureates in the audience and and
other Nobel laureates speaking to those
Noble you know potential novel laureates
speaking to those past Nobel laureates
and I wasn't at that event and um and
the the feeling of of you know creating
something being a part of something only
to see sort of the control taken away
from me that is a big element of the
book and furthermore the the the quest
that drives many scientists you know I
say not all scientists suffer from the
same malady that I did but many of us do
but you know just listening and the few
podcasts that you've done with
scientists and and their fantastic you
know the word Nobel Prize comes up off a
lot and it's sort of a way and of
subconsciously perhaps acknowledging
this Authority bias that human beings
have that we want to have experts to
listen to We want to offload the
responsibility of thinking for ourselves
it's just honest we want to trust that
Einstein knew better than us so he won
the Nobel Prize and he came up with the
photon and special relativity so I'm
going to listen to him
um about uh World Government being the
ideal situation and you know I don't
know how you feel about that but people
I think you you are totally right we
sometimes afford
um we have four particular intellectual
thinkers uh an almost Universal level of
admiration which you know Sir Isaac
Newton there we go like fantastic like
listen to him about physics probably
don't listen to him about what you
should do with you Sunday afternoon like
exactly yeah and it's called the halo
effect it's called the halo effect
people want to believe that there'll be
people you know so in America every four
years we get this list of of Nobel
laureates that say you know which
Democrat you should I've never seen them
once say they should vote for Republican
now you could say whatever you want
about Republicans Or democrats but you
know if it's scientific there should
have been at least like one who would
you know uh you know it's hard to
believe this the group think is so
perfect but it is and that's only wow it
totally totally is this was the the I'll
give you the
um 30 second synopsis to my podcast with
Sabina uh for anyone who is listening if
you go back Sabina hasenfelder
um the beauty in physics I think it was
called the episode and um the the bottom
line the punch line of the whole thing
was that I had discovered during the
podcast that physicists were people too
and I always presumed that they were
these input process output robotic
um a kind of Paragons of perfect
intellectual
pureness and and it turns out that it's
just it's just as political if not more
political than
so many you know it made me feel like my
job which is manipulating social
networks to get people to go to
nightclubs almost felt like relatively
kind of noble and then on the flip side
there's all of the you've got to be in
this right Camp you've got to be you
can't be backstabbing this person or
you've you've adeared yourself to this
particular kind of theory that means you
can't be in this and I I couldn't I
couldn't believe just how bipartisan and
and try parties are in all the rest of
it it was it blew me away it really is
and it's a way of just
oversimplification which is a natural
human urge and it just proves yeah that
that humans a scientists are human and I
think the cliche the Trope that we're
just walking wikipedias is is really
nonsensical and I do my best to you know
display the humanity of the scientists
by both making many many mistakes every
day you can answer my my wife about that
uh but also you know having a having a
real clear-cut you know kind of image of
what is what is uh important about
science so if you look at science the
word science in Greek roughly translates
into knowledge
um but that's very different than wisdom
as I always point out to my colleagues
you know just because you're a scientist
it has nothing to say whatsoever about
your wisdom I mean uh someone know about
Laureate he was actually here at Saint
UC San Diego where I am he said if you
think that Nobel laureates are so
brilliant you should see them in the
morning of the event when they're trying
to find where the eggs are served you
know which is you know another cliche
but at the same time you know again I
don't have problems with the with the
Nova laureates who win I have an issue
with this with the with this process
with this establishment which like what
Sabina talks about both of our books
have a similarity in that we're taking
on these sacred cows and sacred cows are
not always you know deserving of that
stature and I think in the case of the
Nobel prizes health is such high esteem
that one should be careful about the
outsize influence that it has on
scientists certainly uh but especially
on non-scientists members of the public
members of your audience when they hear
Nobel Prize oh they're just going to
stop thinking are there like I'll listen
to what he and it's mostly Men by the
way which is already a tip-off that
there's something rotten in Stockholm
right I mean you know there's many
anyone who thinks that women aren't as
bright as men you know so why is it true
that that only you you know one percent
of all winners of the Nobel Prize in
physics and chemistry are women there's
something obviously at work that's
systemic that needs to be changed and
yet the novel institution is incredibly
ossified uh and and really susceptible
in my mind
uh to a vast Reformation that they're
very unwilling to to do and can you take
us through the what the Nobel Prize is
because you know the the term of the
Nobel Prize I know it and again I am Mr
avatar for the lay lay person so you
know I know that the Nobel Prize is
given in a number of different
categories I know that it's maybe once
every year or once every couple of years
and I know that lots of Jewish people
win it like those are those are kind of
that's the beginning and the end of my
knowledge I don't know why it exists I
don't know where it started I don't know
who looks after I don't know what the
process is or whatever it is so yeah
give us give us the cliff notes on what
the Nobel Prize is so my book begins
with the story of how Alfred nobel's
younger brother blew himself up and it's
kind of weird like what does that have
to do with cosmology so Alfred Nobel was
a was a Swedish actually Russian Swedish
and um uh inventor and entrepreneur who
is the son of a of a father who had
invented some military applications for
high explosives in the 1850s in in
Sweden and had mainly been selling them
to the to the Russian Empire for their
many wars that they were conducting in
that time period uh but the goal of
having a stable form of nitroglycerin
which is very very powerful explosive
but also very Mercurial and explosive
that uh and dangerous that was a goal of
many many inventors that would be the
killer app that could be used to safely
do construction uh if could be invented
so Alfred nobel's younger brother so he
was one of seven kids I believe Alfred
and uh three or four of them died before
they were 22 years old mostly by you
know natural causes but in the case of
his younger brother he was experimenting
with this compound nitroglycerin and he
dropped a vial of it and it blew up the
laboratory in Stockholm where he was
working in the family laboratory killed
uh about four other people that were his
lab assistants and that really drove a
manual Nobel the the Nobel brother's
father insane and he ended up giving
control the company to one of his other
brothers and uh one thing led to another
but Alfred went off on this Quest
single-minded Focus to find uh to find a
safe version of nitroglycerin and he
invented it and it made him perhaps one
of the richest people of the world of
that time and today's dollars worth you
know billions of dollars uh and and this
company that still Bears his name exists
which is which is amazing there are very
few companies you know that are based on
an invention uh by an inventor from the
from the 19th century that still have
that name that still exists I mean maybe
10 of them around the world in this case
um and made them incredibly wealthy but
it was still tied to the manufacturer
and sales of arms uh between uh you know
different countries in Europe that were
continually at war with one another and
then also dynamite in ballastite and all
sorts of other military cordite
explosives used to kill people and one
day about 20 years after he invented
dynamite Alfred was walking around the
streets of Paris France and He Came Upon
a headline and said Alfred Nobel The
Merchant of death as dead and the man
who had killed more people in history
than any other person has met his own
just reward they were kind of gleefully
celebrating his death and uh it was very
shocking to him it must have felt like
uh you know Ebenezer Scrooge or you know
somebody like really celebrating their
death and it shocked him so much that he
resolved to use his vast personal
Fortune after he died to endow a will
which would give out prizes in five
categories literature medicine physics
chemistry and P
and so piece kind of the one that little
bit stands out but all all five of these
Awards and they've since enlarged it to
include economics about 80 years after
he died
and they're given out annually and what
Alfred wanted and he said explicitly in
his will which you can find the Nobel
commit on the Nobel Prize website to
this day he said I want these prizes to
go to to the person
in the singular who created the most
important or beneficial Discovery or
invention in the preceding year that has
had the biggest benefit on mankind so
there are three stipulations a single
person would win it for an invention
made last year and that had the greatest
benefit on mankind now unless your
theoretical particle physicist I don't
know how much the Higgs boson improves
your daily life or benefits your daily
life you know if you if you do then you
know please consult a psychiatrist but
because you know it's really not that
relevant to our daily lives very
important in the grand scheme of the
universe but it would it would exist
whether we discovered it or not unlike
say the X-ray which was the subject of
the first Nobel Prize 1901 which has
improved and better the lives of human
beings is that what got the first Nobel
Prize yeah so I talk about that that's a
pretty cool pretty sort of big uh big
impact yeah Discovery right absolutely
and there have been other ones and so so
my point book because what happened was
as I said Chris I I was you know created
this experiment which was immediately uh
claimed to be Nobel worthy the day of
the announcement in 2014. which you
weren't there for
which uh what's that which you weren't
there for you weren't there yeah so I
talked about that a very bad I'm very
honest in the book about you know my my
foibles and faults in the whole uh
Affair but um but in truth you know I
think it ended up being that there were
competitions and there were discussions
and polls on the internet and papers
published you know that really claimed
that of all the you know kind of people
on Earth that I might have a decent shot
you know better than one in in five or
something of winning a Nobel Prize which
is pretty high you know because there's
you know billions of people on earth
right and and how often do you get to be
in that very select group and then uh as
I described in the book it was not to be
obviously the title would be different
if I had won the Nobel Prize not lost it
so the title of losing the Nobel Prize
but it has two different meanings one of
the meanings is how I personally lost it
and lost out on this opportunity
although creating something Nobel Worthy
and then having that slip away I
describe the emotions of that and the
personal side of that but also the
cosmic side of it what does it mean to
talk about things like the Multiverse
and like the inflationary universe and
the creation of of the Big Bang uh what
does that mean in a world in a universe
that's polluted with contamination and
with confirmation bias and with all
these other foibles that human beings
have so that's one aspect of the title
but then if you can imagine this uh you
know so imagine
um what is it uh Prince Harry you know
he and Princess Megan you know they want
to come to a club and and you're at that
club and they're about to come into your
club and you hooked it up they're just
so you're just gonna love it you're
gonna take selfies with it and then
right before they get there they say you
know what we're not going to come to
your club or any of your clubs in fact
could you recommend a better club uh for
us to go to better than any of the ones
here so what ended up happening was not
only did I lose the Nobel Prize chance
that I uh you know best chance I would
ever have but that same year that I
potentially could have won it I was
asked by the Swedish Royal Academy and
Sciences to nominate the winners of the
Nobel Prize that you know I would have
won had my experiment not been
disconfirmed and our results retracted
wow our claim of Discovery retract the
experiment was correct it still is
correct we still believe it's true but
the interpretation of what we saw has
been changed radically from detecting
the imprimatur of God if you like or of
the Big Bang of nature uh to the most
humble substance in the universe this
Cosmic dust that I describe at some
length in the book I was going to say
what's the specifics about because
you've gone from you you were there you
would at the Finish Line ready to go but
it seems like there's kind of two
elements to this story one of them is
the potentially systemic more political
the side that I want to hear a little
bit more about how the Nobel Prize is a
judged and stuff like that but the
obviously the sort of meat and veg of it
is the fact that what you found was
interpreted differently to what you
originally thought is that correct can
you take us through that yeah so when we
set out to measure the universe's
earliest light and this curling twisting
pattern that gives bicep its name Etc
the the experiment was designed to see
an effect in other words it was designed
to see this leftover Aftershock of the
Big Bang via gravitational waves and so
it wasn't designed to necessarily rule
out every other uh potential source of
cosmic mimicry so there could be sources
that we did know about say the Earth
emits a type of signal that could be
mistaken for it so we designed the
experiment to block out the signal from
the earth because we had to locate it at
the South Pole on Earth uh similarly say
the atmosphere could do it or there
could be emission from sources that are
not cosmological but they are in the in
the solar system or in the galaxy and we
knew about those sources we did our best
to eliminate them but there was one
source uh that we simply did not have
enough information and there was one
group of astronomers that had this
information in fact they were LED from
the European Space Agency it was a
satellite called the Planck satellite
and they had measured the sky and they
we knew that they had information which
could tell us if we had seen Cosmic dust
which are particles grains of carbon
nickel iron particles left over from the
previous explosion of a generation of
stars called the Supernova that may have
existed that did exist in our galaxy
prior to our Solar System's existence
and other solar systems existence and
without such supernovae we would
probably not exist because the iron in
your blood the hemoglobin molecule that
carries iron molecules iron atoms that
was forged those iron molecules were
forged in the core of a supernova that
exploded in our local Stellar
neighborhood 4.9 billion years ago so
you literally as Carl Sagan used to say
you know have Stardust falling through
your blood uh very poetically but it
also flows through the Galaxy and
because it's made of iron just like the
filings as Michael Faraday showed and
others showed they align themselves in
magnetic fields or our Milky Way galaxy
has a magnetic field 2 and it can
produce the exact same curling twisting
pattern of microwaves as the Big Bangs
inflationary Epoch could so that was uh
the signal that we mistook and the
reason that we didn't have access to
information which would have
disconfirmed our claim earlier is
because it was held by our competitors
the plank satellite did not want to
share this information with us we didn't
know if they had detected it as well as
we had and wanted to scoop us out of
this discovery and potentially win their
own Nobel Prize or they didn't have a
good understanding yet of their own
deficiencies so forth with their
instrument and it turned out to probably
be a little of both but there's this
incredible competition that exists
within science to get there not only get
there first but to just obliterate the
competition like leave no doubt that you
made this definitive measurement we
wanted that to be clear throughout the
entire paper press conference everything
we did that there should be no doubt
that what we discovered was what we
claimed and in the end the results were
correct but we made a very Exquisite
measurement of the emission from dust
particles in our in our local Galactic
neighborhood uh incredibly challenging
by the way because the signals that we
saw were just a few parts in a billion
out of the temperature of the South
Poles just Exquisite technology I
describe how exciting it is this
technology and how it's progressing and
will progress based on the lessons
learned from bicep 2 to build a next
generation of instrumentation and such
as the Simon's Observatory which is a
big project that I am a leader leading
here in San Diego around based with
institutions around the world
literally 250 researchers on every
continent you know currently in the on
the planet which is amazing to think
about so uh the the real Discovery and
and its aftermath and how it affected me
and the field personally uh is really
tied up in this Quest at least
personally for me with the Nobel Prize
and I came to see it in a sense as
almost a false idol and I came to see
the Nobel Prize in a sense as a religion
as a type of religion ironically
practiced by mostly secular scientists
right 70 of Our National Academy of
Sciences declare themselves to be
atheists not not agnostic but atheists
and and yet they they're if you go to
any website you know that supports
science or any Discovery where you know
the the upper echelons of authority need
to be referenced and even in sabina's
books and she's not you know really
beholden to them but she you know
constantly is interviewing Nobel
laureates and talking about things that
were rewarded with the Nobel Prize and
saying well nothing's been awarded the
Nobel Prize citizens you know in
theoretical physics shows you how you
know how poor these predictions yeah as
a scorecard as a Talisman as an icon and
I and I make these parallels between a
religion and the Nobel Prize and I I
think you know they're they're quite you
know I think that nobody really disputes
it which is kind of interesting to me uh
nobody disagrees with the Reformation so
I present five ways to improve the Nobel
Prize before it's too late because I
think if you have an institution that
refuses to change its operating you know
mode that it's at risk of catastrophic
you know kind of existential crisis well
it loses it loses its Purity right like
the whole point again for me as someone
who doesn't know what he's talking about
the the one of the only things that I
want the Nobel Prize to do is for it to
go to the right person yeah do you know
so poor people right more people I want
to I want to get on to what the uh
process for the Nobel Prize consists of
but just the the final thing that I want
to kind of round off the story for you
personally was
um how did you find out about the fact
that there had been this particular
change in how your
um how your Discovery had been viewed
and then what was the next sort of what
were the next couple of days like uh I'm
fascinated to hear what that what that
means to someone who's pushed so hard
and and come so close yeah yeah it was
it was a mixture of emotions uh you know
first obviously embarrassment uh a
little personal sense of humiliation
that you know I had kind of gone along
with this result even though I had some
doubts about it as we we all had doubts
but but certainly I had voiced a lot of
doubts and you know a little bit bit of
gratitude that you know I had I'd not
been you know so publicly associated
with the face of this detection because
I had been kind of eliminated which
which I described in the book and how
this role I wasn't eliminated completely
obviously but uh but the way the
announcement was made I was you know
prevented from being a part of it so
bizarrely the thing the thing that you
felt a little bit uh maybe jilted uh
you'd kind of been left at the altar so
to speak when it came to the the glory
but in a roundabout fashion that had
also protected you from being the
figurehead who upon whose shoulders most
of the
um the backlash had had landed I suppose
that's right exactly right and yeah so
you know I just admit that you know how
it felt uh I wasn't you know glad I
wanted us to be right I wanted to be
right even if I didn't win the Nobel
Prize but you know in the end the day
new month of the story for me became a
recognition that as I said ironically
all these scientists are atheists but
they worshiped this golden crucifix of
an icon the Nobel Prize which literally
has a Graven image you know a picture of
Alfred Nobel on it and you bow down to
it on the day he was he died in in
December 10 you know December 10th 1896
that's what the day that they're awarded
on his birthday uh and and for me this
this kind of religion no longer holds
the idolatrous transfiction that it had
once before and that it uh it no longer
really consumes my my daily life in any
way other than you know to think that
the privilege of getting paid to do the
research that I get to do and work with
the genius p people students and other
scientists around the world that I get
to work with that is reward enough and
when we make the Nobel Prize this
Paragon of scientific Excellence we are
kind of reducing ourselves sorry to say
you know to kind of like entertainers in
the Hollywood Oscars inside pop Idol or
X Factor right yeah exactly exactly and
and and for us I think you know
scientists should be the most immune
from that right aren't we supposed to be
hyper rational and these Paragons of
intellectual honesty but I think you
know we're human beings and the problem
is that you know I as I often say I did
an interview with Scott Eastwood who's
you know Clint Eastwood's son a very
famous podcaster here in the in the
states and you know saying like well you
don't really expect you know a movie
studio uh doesn't really expect that all
of its films are gonna win Academy
Awards I mean some of them you know are
going to be like the Fast and the
Furious and they're just not working
he's like I was in the Fast and the
Furious
that was a highlight of my podcasting
career
um but but you know but he agreed with
me you know it's like the the actors and
actresses who go into Hollywood they
don't go into it saying oh I'm only a
good actor if I win a Nobel Prize but or
an Oscar rather but the studios you
better believe they want most of their
pictures to get that's why they have 10
different Globe nominations
right all these things Sundance and
they're all about giving each other
rewards and the no there is no second
there is no Golden Globes or sag
comparison you know second runner-up for
the Nobel prone there's just nothing
like that so it puts the Nobel Prize
under great scrutiny and holds it up to
this level of
of really austere of being you know just
the augustness of winning it uh I think
that it that it does a detriment has a
detrimental effect on scientists but to
the extent it's going to survive I
wanted to preserve the purity of it by
making certain reformations I talk about
as I say five of the ways that you could
do it one of those I've been invited to
nominate winners of the Nobel Prize and
coming upon it you know as a scholar
would so I received a letter a couple of
weeks after we met you know the final
nail in the coffin for our detection
back in 2014 and I got a letter from the
Royal Swedish Academy which said you
know do not talk strictly confidential
you know so I guarantee it's the last
time I'll be asked to nominate winners
but but it said you know here's what you
need to do look for the multiple winners
you know who deserve the prize it could
be something done decades earlier and it
could and it didn't mention anything
about having a benefit on mankind I said
Alfred only said three things in his
will it has to go to one person in the
preceding year who has the greatest
benefit and here they are asking me to
do nothing of what he asked me to do and
I felt like well that's kind of one of
the worst things you could do is not is
not have uh respect for the wishes of a
dead man right a dead man has one chance
a one will and imagine you know you know
you're gonna live you know 100 more
years or whatever but you write your
will someday and you say I want all the
money to go to Oxfam or whatever and
they give it to like you know whatever I
don't even know what they would give it
to
uh but they give it or you know Green
Piece and they give it to Exxon Mobil or
BP you know you'd be pretty pissed off
but what could you do nothing absolutely
nothing because you're dead and and so I
felt like it's become it's be it's
incumbent upon scientists like me to
advocate for change from within and I
don't have any you know illusion
delusion that they're gonna listen to me
uh but I felt the story was too
important to ignore and so far I've
gotten great feedback from people around
the world scientists and lay people
about what it's like to really aspire to
this and and to really make great
important discoveries but not judge
yourself on whether or not this you know
three inch diameter gold you know
Medallion like a rap star would wear you
know goes around your neck I could see
you I could have seen you with that raft
around your neck which is a shame but
there's a couple of things a couple of
things I've been thinking about as
you've been speaking that one of them
the first thing that you said was that
um the humiliation maybe came a little
bit higher than the disappointment and
um some listeners of the show will know
that I came off a motorbike in Bali a
couple of years ago and I'm driving
along no
driving at 50 pence per day Balinese uh
moped which is my that was my first
error the second error is not really
being very good at riding a motorbike
and a truck pulls out in front of me and
I come off the bike anyway and I'm
wearing a tiny pair of swim shorts and a
little vest and um I just it's me versus
Balinese road and it wins all day like
I've got kind of like second-degree
burns on half of my body and most of the
left-hand side of me is stuck in the
Balinese tarmac which is very cool it's
perfect for removing skin it'd be a
brilliant cheese grater and um the the
first thing that I felt so I was riding
with these two Aussie guys who I had
made friends with while I was out there
I was traveling on my own I'd made
friends with these two Aussie guys and
they kind of knew me and I kind of knew
them beforehand but anyway we relatively
new friends and I was in Mortal danger
I'd just injured myself like the
Forefront of my mind should have been my
injury and the first thing that I felt
when I stood myself up and brushed bits
of tarmac out of me was embarrassment
the the ahead of uh Abraham Maslow's
hierarchy of needs like forget the fact
about like I was worried about I'm
injured or is this gonna SCAR or uh you
know is another car coming is there
going to be another car behind me that
hits me no no I wanted to stand up and
think oh you like that's the first
thing that I thought and I it's just so
telling of the fact that we are
no matter how as you say these sort of
Paragons of of beautiful intellectual
truth and and
um
Purity and all the rest of this stuff
it's born out of a flawed system and
that system is human and the other thing
is that I think is is really super
interesting is this the the journey that
it's allowed you to go on which I think
is a lot of a lot of people will be able
to draw a comparison with which is kind
of that of discovering that the the
process of what you have created that
life is a process of becoming not being
and that as you've gone along the way
you're now able to look back on it and
say well you know like the fact that I
was able to bring all of these people
together and
in a very bizarre way I wonder whether
or not you would have the same level of
nuanced and subtle appreciation for all
of the different elements if it was
overshadowed by a large award I don't
know whether you'd be able to look back
with the same degree of High Fidelity
that granular kind of yeah absolutely no
I I agree with you 100 I mean I always
joke you know people say oh you're a
hypocrite you wouldn't turn a Nobel
Prize down if you want I say well if you
want to see how if I'm sincere just get
them to award me the Nobel Prize
in all seriousness you know I feel like
um yeah it's almost a blessing because
it's sort of like a Liberation you know
I don't know if you're married or
whatever but I always say you know when
I met my wife I I got to stop like going
on dates like I never have to have a
first date again you know hopefully yeah
it's very liberating when you when you
free your mind of it and so when I freed
my mind of obsession about I was told to
get tenure to get to high level of
promotion at the University of
California I have to win a Nobel Prize
I've been told by many people that
they're basically judged in their
careers on their prospects of winning a
Nobel Prize to be liberal from that and
say like well you know that is that is
completely an asinine a metric by which
to judge a human being and I say in the
book you know the journey is more
important than the Gilded destination
and you know we make fun of like you
know I don't know if you you know
whatever how biblical you want to get
but you know back in the Bible it talks
about the the Israelites worshiping a
golden calf you know this this icon made
of gold that they made themselves uh you
know a few weeks after witnessing God
allegedly you know wipe out Egypt with
all these plagues right and I thought
that's so silly but but in truth you
know 3 000 years later here we are doing
the exact same thing we worship a golden
icon with a picture of Alfred Nobel and
that is part of the way that we value
our self-worth I think that that's a
shame in a modern scientific Society to
feel that way and so I feel like it's
part of my you know one of the lessons
learned and how to handle it it's not
just about you know losing a Nobel Prize
which you know probably all of your
listeners can sympathize with but how do
you handle now not winning you know top
50 podcasts or how do you handle not not
you know getting to you know be high
school class president these are all
things that P you know you're far more
likely not to get into your own personal
promise length and then than to get in
it and that's okay right you're not
going to get in to be Manchester United
or new what is your team Newcastle uh
the good whatever
um so you know from my perspective so
how do you handle that because that's
the state if you look at the probability
distribution of what you're going to
spend your life being it's not being a
Nobel Prize winner it's not being this
is Burrito as it comes isn't it exactly
exactly so I hope that people you know
will enjoy the the journey and not
fixate on the destination uh let's hope
the journey is a lot more successful
than your balance motorcycle Journey
though yeah that would be nice I think
it's um it's super super interesting to
speak to yourself especially after
having spoken to Sabina and to hear just
how Folly some of the elements of
science are and you know the the
something that was super interesting
that we kind of moved past was when you
had the European space agency and they
didn't Supply you with the particular
types of information that you needed
that would have helped you further your
research and you think like I think from
my side things like physics especially
when we're talking about making
developments and learning about the
universe is the same as medicine in that
the goal should be as wide and as vast
progression as expedited as is possible
but you that's not what happens it
becomes narrow and deep because there's
certain information that will benefit
one particular group and over another
and etc etc and
I don't know I think removing ego from
the situation is it is going to be
impossible and you can't litigate for it
you know you're not going to be able to
have someone coming in and say on you
need to share your research with these
people or whatever and as well we can
talk all we want and the the listeners
will be in the midst once we are
broadcast you'll be in the midst of some
very mindful other guests that we've had
Rick Hansen and and
Corey Allen and all these meditation
experts you know detach from the ego and
all this sort of stuff but yeah on the
flip side like
telling someone who's won something
fantastic like yo man like you should
have never even gone for that in the
first place you should detach from your
ego you're like well no off like I
worked really really hard for this and
I'm the one that got it and because that
story is newsworthy and all the ones of
the runners-up aren't
you would definitely you inevitably end
up with this asymmetry of glorification
yeah but exactly who's going to advocate
for reform right are there people that
win it have a vested interest in it you
know I note that there have been
peacemakers who turned on the Nobel
Peace Prize right oh yeah I wanted I
wanted to ask that what what does the
piece what do you make a Peace Prize how
does that work what do you have to do I
mean some of it's been you know it's
it's one of the few prizes that anybody
can nominate anybody for so you could
nominate me I could nominate you
yeah
yeah but the physics prize you have to
be invited right and one of the
Criterion to be invited is that you won
a Nobel Prize that's one option so the
rich get richer if you want a Nobel
Prize you're a graduate student and
postdoc is much more likely to get a
Nobel Prize or universally if you work
for somebody you're likely to go so I go
through all these kind of different
machinations within it but you know I
think like there there is sort of a
vested interest in keeping look the
Nobel Prize is a monopoly it's the most
prestigious Award of its kind just like
the Oscars or Monopoly yeah there are
other Runners up but it's it's pretty
Head and Shoulders above them right but
the noble there is no real secondary
competitor to it I mean I challenge you
know people to know about it uh and so
as such it has a huge responsibility to
inform the public about how science is
actually done now describe in the books
some of the cruel aspects of the Nobel
Prize wherein you know people that you
know mostly women but but sometimes men
as well uh including just a year two
years ago when one of you know
Scotland's greatest scientists Ron
draver was basically written out of
History because he happened to die you
know six months before the Nobel Prize
for ligo was awarded and it's all part
of these crazy rules that they like to
adhere to that they themselves choose
and pick what to apply as I say they
don't follow what Alfred wanted so I
hope your listeners get a chance to
engage with it I welcome we have a
couple websites we set up one is just
called losing the nobelprize.com where
people can suggest winners and put a
petition kind of like the moveon.org
strategy
and then I have a mailing list on my
website briancating.com uh that that
people can engage with I love hearing
from people how it's affected them uh
and it's it's it's gotten a lot of good
attention I used to think well you know
I shouldn't even care about like whether
it wins these awards for best books of
the year uh but you know just getting
drawn straight back in again I did I'm
like yeah I can't even be I can't even
be stoic anymore it's like I'm too I'm
too fortunate no it's it's really it's
uh receive a lot of lovely attention and
so yeah I'm really interested to hear
what you think about it and I'm excited
to read it I really I really really am I
think the the minutia and I'm I'm
looking forward to finding out the
sordid details about what goes on behind
the scenes and and stuff like that so
yeah it's it's been a Plus thank you so
much for coming on I really appreciate
your time thank you so much and let's
keep in touch Chris I certainly will do
links to everything will be in the show
notes below please make sure that you
follow Brian online he has a very
interesting Twitter feed and his website
will be linked below so man thank you
catch you later on thank you so much
Chris
[Music]